우리 팀장님한테 여쭤 보고 싶은게
있어요. 문화 차원에서 네네.
>> 자, 우리가 자원은 한정돼 있거든요.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 그런데
>> 예를 들어서 뭐 홍길동은행에 어
1억이 들어왔어요. 근데 이제
고민스럽단 말이죠. 자, 1천명을
진원할 건가? 100명을 확실히
진원할 건가?
>> 자, 어떤게 더 효과적이라고
생각하세요? 여기서 효과라는 건
뭐냐면 전 모르겠습니다. 근데 기부를
생각하실 때
>> 과연 더 많은 사람들에게 혜택을
주는게 혹은 지원을 하는게 맞을까?
아니면 아주 소수라도 확실하게 해
줘서
>> 실제적인 변화를 일으키는게 좋을까요?
어 정말
>> 좋 좋은 질문이고 어려운 질문인 거
같습니다.
>> 어 근데 그게 방향성이 정해지셔야
되는 거 아닙니까?
>> 아 저희 저희의 방향성에 대해서
질문하시는
>> 그렇죠. 그렇죠. 예를 들어서
아름다운 제단도 그렇고 일단 이제
안소장님도 이제 여쭤볼 건데
>> 네
>> 어 그 방향성이 더해 줘야 사업
사업의 일종에
잡히잖아요.
>> 예 맞습니다. 저희 재단의 기본적인
방향성은
>> 어 그 둘 중에 하나를 선택하라면
투자인 거 같아요. 그래서 확실하게
변화시킬 수 있는 것을 우리가
>> 지켜낸다. 왜냐하면은 어 공익 단체의
역할이라는 것이 정부가 복지나 이런
서비스로 제공하지 못하는 것을
대신하는 것이란 말이에요. 그렇다면은
정부에서 못하는 것을 훨씬 더
혁신적으로 그리고 확실히 문제를
해결할 수 있는 방향으로 사업을
설계를 하고 그것이 이루어지면 이후에
확장되는 방식 또는 그것이 제도화되는
방식을 저희가 추구하고 있거든요.
방실
어떤 과를 해는 방향으로 하고 그것이
확대될 수 있는 것을 또 저희가
강구하는 그런 방향으로 사업을
진행하고 있다고 보는게 맞을 것
>> 같 어떻게 생각하세요?
>> 아름다운 재단이 실제 그렇게 해서
성공했던 거 같아.
그룹 아운 기부를 해
>> 어 미혼 모정을 도와줬는데
>> 그 돈을 전국의들을 모아 가지고
최대한 많이 1/로 뿌릴 수
있었겠죠.데 재단은 보니까 그렇게 안
하고 식당 창업을 창업을 연결해
주더라고요.
>> 아
>> 그니까 돈은 좀 더 들어가죠.
네정들어
식당 창업면 쉽지 않잖아요. 그분이
요리도 거고 상권도 분석해야 될 거고
그래서 그 가게를 여러 점을 냈어요.
>> 음
>> 그분이 자리을 완전히 도와주는 거죠.
10을 내리면 뭐 300만 원을 존해
주는 방법도 있을 수 있잖아요. 그게
아니라
>> 1천만 원, 2천만 원이 들더라도
>> 식당 영업을 통해서 자립할 수 있도록
>> 음
>> 그니까 아예 중장기적으로 자립이
가능하게 그래서 그거는 재단히 정말
그건 잘해 온 거 같고요. 뭐이어서
좀 말씀드리고 싶은게 지금 말씀하신
사업이 희망가게라는 사업이거든요.
제가 재단에 왔을 때 처음 이제
담당하게 된 업무였는데 희망가게
사업이 한부모 여정 어을 자립을
지원하는 사업이고 소
>> 아 제가 맞네요. 미혼모 아니라
미모도 포함 한모 여성 경제적 자립을
지원하는 건데 그래서 그 당시에
반글라데시의 마이크로크레디 사업이라는
것이 굉장히 성공을 했었거든요.
대출해 준 거예요. 예. 무담보로
굉장히 저리로 저희가 일단 1%를
받았던 거 같아요. 그리고 신용
분량자도 상관이 없었어요. 대체
굉장히 어려우신 분들이었는데 그래서
어 창업을 통해서 최대 4천만 원까지
이제 배출을 해 드리고 사업을
했었는데 그 자금이 아머네퍼시픽
창업주가 돌아가시면서가 유가족이
그분을 기리기 위해서 주식으로 기부를
하셨어요.
>> 그 당시 그 당시 금액으로
50억이었거든요. 어마어마한 금액을
정말 기부를 하셨는데 그 기 주식
기부를 통해서 다 그리고 굉장히 어
저희가 상황이 좋게도 주식이 계속
많이 올랐어요. 그래서 그 주식을
팔아서 이제 배출을 또 할 수 있어서
지금까지도 그 사업이 영의가 되고
있고 제가 처음으로 주식을 산 계기가
어 아머레퍼시피에서 이제 주식을
기부해서이 사업을 하고 있는데 또
언제도 다시 기부하실지 모르잖아요.
그러려면은 어 회사가 좀 잘 돼야
되고 그러면 주식이 오를 텐데 그럼
내가 주식을 사서 한번 봐야겠다라고
해서 두 주를 당시에 샀는데 100만
원이 조금 안 됐어요. 한 주에
100만 원이 조금 안 됐어요.
>> 그래서 큰아들 대학 보내려고 이렇게
모아놓은 적금이 만기가 돼서 두 주를
샀는데 이게네 배가 올라가지고 이제
팔아야 되는데 당시 저는
>> 팔 줄을 몰랐어요.
10년이 더 지난 후에 팔았는데 결국
한 두 배 정도에 팔고 어쨌건 그게
인연이 돼서 주식 기부가 가능하다는
것도 많이 알려줬고 그리고 현재
제달에서는 저도 몇 년 전까지만 해도
아들한테 주식을 이제 뭐 선선물
주겠다. 왜 그런 걸 하냐라고
했었는데 현재는 아까 말씀하신 그런
자립 준비 청년들을 대상으로 자산을
키워 나가기 위해서 미래셋하고 저희가
연계를 해 가지고 ETF를 투자하는
지원을 하기도 하거든요. 그래서 그런
방식의 어떤 기업과 또 이런
주식이라는 자산을 이용해서 지원도
가능하다. 그래서 이런 다양한 방식의
기부가 지금 확대되 있다라고. 그건
되게 좋네요.
안녕하세요. 코스피가 8,이 돼도
9천이 돼도 1만이 돼도 여러분들의
밥 친구가 되고 싶은 12시에 만나이
광수입니다. 여러분 주가 오른다고
버리시면 안 됩니다.
여러분 옆에 박시동 대표님 계십니다.
>> 아네 박시동입니다. 거짓말하지
마세요. 만 되면 다 털고 사라진다고
들어오시기 그랬잖아요. 만대면
그만하자고.
>> 아 저희가 12시에 만나요잖아요.
여기서 많이 그 많이예요.
>> 아 많. 여기까지만. 아, 그랬구나.
>> 아이, 많이 되면 좀 생각해 보도록
하겠습니다. 권장표 님 계십니다.
>> 제가 지금 저희 PD 님들의 열정
여러분 보이니까
>> 그렇습니다. 저희 10만 대군을
위해서로
>> 좀 부탁드려요. 아니,
>> 12시에 만나요. 10만.
>> 네. 아니, 동자 중요합니다.
>> 동접자 10만 이야기를 했는데 저희가
뭐라도 할까요? 했는데이 연휴 사이에
바로 이렇게 준비를 해서
오셨더라고요. 바로 게시해
보았습니다. 너무 좋습니다.
>> 올리지. 우리 같으면 안 돼.
>> 그러니깐요. 근데 벌써 어 저희가
말씀 이미 드렸잖아요. 그러니까
댓글로 안겨 주셨는데 PC 들고
>> 노트북 들고 휴대폰 틀고 근데 여러분
하나가 빠졌어요.
>> 뭐요?
>> 패드 빠졌어.
다단계 방식으로 갑니다. 자,
1인당네 개로 하겠습니다.네 개.
예. 그러면 뭐 한 3만 돼도
되잖아요.
>> 예. 여러분 함께 해 주셔서 너무
감사하고 또 오늘 주식 시장이에
상승하면서 출발을 해서 기분 좋게
출발 해 보도록 하겠습니다. 오늘
시황을 좀 정리해 볼까요?
>> 네. 바로 가보도록 하겠습니다. 어,
현재 코스피지수 12시 1분 기준으로
8,75포인트
지나가고 있습니다. 오늘의 가장 큰
특징이라고 한다면 현재 외국인이
코스피, 코스닥 선물까지도 매수를
하면서 지수가 끌어올려지고 있습니다.
코스닥 같은 경우는 1177포인트
지나가고 있고요. 아, 환율이 조금만
더 잡혔으면 좋겠네요. 1508원
지나가고 있습니다. 뉴스 한 가지씩
열어 보시죠. 첫 번째로는 역시나
전쟁 종료 기대에 8천선 6거래일
만에 재털한했다라는
이야기입니다. 말씀드린 대로
외국인들이 연일 팔다가 오늘 오랜만에
매수세 들어오고 있습니다. 두
번째로는 드디어 내일 삼성전자와 SK
하이닉스의 두 배 레버리지 ETF가
상장이 됩니다. 어떤 점들 확인해야
하는지 함께 체크해 보시죠. 세
번째로는 아 정말 잘 갑니다.
삼성전기 현재 158만 원 지나가고
있는데요.
MLCC 가격 인상 사이클
초입이다라고 하면서 목표 주가
200만 원까지 나오고 있습니다.
관련된 종목들 살펴보시죠.
마지막으로는 장초반에 갑자기 조선주가
급등하기 시작했습니다. 이재명
대통령이 핵추진 잠수함 도입 속도
내야 한다라는 코멘트가 나오면서
캐나다 잠수함에 대한 기대도 함께
커지고 있습니다. 현재 조선주들 6,
7% 이상의 상승세 보여주고
있습니다. 지금까지 정호의 머닝 뉴스
정리해 드렸습니다.
>> 네, 감사합니다. 오늘 어쨌든 시장이
상승하는게 가장 큰 뉴스인데요. 어
어제 뭐 니게일를 중심으로 해서
아시아 시장에 크게 상승했기 때문에
좀 예측된 측면이 있었죠네.
맞습니다.
>> 네.
>> 어땠어요?
어제 사실 또 더 좋았던게 막판까지
대망가권이랑 니케이 지수가 어제
기준으로 거의 고가에서 마무리가
됐습니다. 그중에서도 반도체, AI,
MLCC, 기판 이런 종목들이
급등하면서 마감이 돼서
>> 왜 우리 오늘 쉬는 거야?라고
정을
받전자
29,500원선
SK하이닉스 206만 원선
지나갑니다.
>> 많은 분들이 요즘 어 이런
말씀하세요. 휴일이 싫다.
>> 아 올라야 되는데. 네네.
시는게 안 좋다. 어 근데 어쨌든
>> 시장이 전반적으로 상승하는 분기고 그
기저에는 종전 기대감
>> 맞습니다. 일단은 미국과 트럼프
미국과 이란의이 종전을 향한 여러
가지 협상이 지금 일단은 어 좋은
소식들이 일단은 계속 들어오고
있어요. 기대감을 계속 높이는
거고요. 미국 언론이나이란 언론이나
중동 언론에서 단순히 이제 설이
아니라 어 뭐 양해 각서 초안이
나왔어. 네.
>> 특히 이제 핵 관련해서 뭐 폐기
방안이 근접됐어 등등등 해서 좀
구체적인 보도가 나오는 걸로 봐서는음
>> 아 진짜로 이제에
합의 단계가 입막한 거 아니냐라고
해서 일단 종전에 대한 기대감을
높이고 있고요. 그 이제 M
초안이라고 나오고 있는 내용 중에서
핵심은 역시 호르무주죠. 예.
허르무주의에
30일 내의 정상적인 개방 이게 이제
핵심이거든요. 그렇게 되면 일단은
유가 관련해서도 내려갈 요인이 충분히
생기거든요. 그러니까 그 발언 그
보도 그다음에 추가적으로 유가 하락이
이어졌는데 유가가 한동안 계속 배위에
있가 드디어 이제 90대로 확
떨어졌습니다.
>> 네. 네. 현재도 91달러 지나가고
있고요.이 유가가 더 떨어질 것이라고
그니까 호르무즈가 열릴 수 있을
것이라고 보이는 이유는 트럼프
대통령의 트루스 소셜 때문입니다.
우리 시간으로 오늘 오전 6시
45분에 올라왔고요. 포인트는
그겁니다. 핵을 반출해야 한다라고
이야기를 했었잖아요. 근데 트럼프
대통령이 여기서 약간 한 발
뺍니다.이란 내에서 폐기하는 것도
내가 수용할 수 있어라는 내용이
나오면서 전반적으로 시장은 화답하고
있습니다.
>> 네. 그러다 보니까 이제 유가
떨어지고요. 그래서 일단은 우리가
가장 직접적으로 증시에 영향을 미치는
미국채의 에죠.
>> 금리도 지금 안정세로 안정세까진
아니지만 예.
>> 예. 그래도 이제 4.5대까지는
확실하게 내려오고 4.4까지도
잡혔죠.
>> 4.4까지 찍혔다가 오늘 아침에 새로
열린 시장에서는 4.51 10년물
국채금이 지나갔.
>> 그러니까 우리 장 열리기 전까지는
4.4까지는 찍었는데요. 예. 지금
벌어지고 있는 상황은 조금 있다
나중에 뭐 얘기할 수 있음을 하고요.
어쨌거나 그래서 유가, 금리, 또
종전에 관의 기대감 이게 사실은
우리가 쉬는 동안에에 세계 증시에
그동안 눌리고 있던음 여러 가지
걱정거리를 다 거치게 해 줬죠.
그러고 나면 어 거침 없는 거
아니야? 악재가 없잖아. 약간 이런
상황이죠.
>> 네. 음. 그래서 그런 차원에서
우리는 상방을 어디까지 봐야 되는지
좀 고민해 볼 필요가 있는데 여기서
상방은 뭐 코스피 지수가 얼마까지
가겠습니다. 이런 얘기를 드리는게
아니고 동력에 대한 얘기인데
>> 그렇죠.
>> 그러니까 종전에 대한 기대감 해서
반영되는 건 좋습니다. 그런데 결국
주식 시장의 핵심은 누가 사느냐가
중요하잖아요. 그러니까 살 사람이
있느냐. 음.
>> 그런 차원에서 대한민국의 주식 시장이
오늘 의미 있는 변화가 일어나고
있어요. 외국인들이 산다는 건
>> 제가 봤더니 최근 한 달 동안 역대
최고금으로 외국인이 팔았단 말이에요.
그런데 오늘 주식을 산다. 그건 뭔가
변화의 신호를 시장이 주고 있는 거
아닌가? 그러니까 결국 주식을 사면
누군가 사는 주체가 뚜렷하게 나타나면
주가는 굉장히 탄력 있게 오를 수
있어서 어떻게 보세요? 어, 지금
13거래일만에 외국인이 코스피
시장에서 매수로 돌아섰고요. 11시
기준으로 외국인이 가장 많이 사는
것은 역시나 삼성전자와 SK
하이닉스입니다. 근데 이런 분석들이
있더라고요. 국내 IT토 반도체
업종의 외국인 지분율이 10년 내
최저였대요.
>> 아,
>> 근데 사기 시작한다. 그럼 채워야 할
것들이 많잖아요.
>> 굉장히 중요한 얘기예요. 그러니까
너무 많이 팔았어요. 올랐다고.
그런데 보니까 너무 많이 비운
거예요. 네.
>> 그러면 어떻게 해야 됩니까?
>> 너무 많이 비우면 어떻게 해요?
>> 다 채워야죠.
>> 예. 어디까지요?
>> 꼭지까지.
>> 그게 되게 의미가 있는데
>> 이게 채웠다가 늘릴 때는 그 전보다는
더 늘어갈 가능성이 커요.
>> 예. 보통 그럽니다. 그래야 그걸
만해 하잖아요. 그렇기 때문에 저는
>> 어 뭐 계속 강조하는 측면이기도
하지만이 수급 측면에서 외국인
매수세가 한국의 증시에 굉장히 큰
탄력을 만들 수 있다라는 생각을 좀
가져봅니다. 네. 음. 그래서
어쨌거나 오늘은 뭐 글로벌의 증시들을
다 누르고 있던 악재들이 일단은 좀
거친 느낌이고요. 그러니까 뭐
외국인이든 우리이 국민 투자자건
기관이건 일단은 사는데 주저함은
없어요.
말씀드는냐이
어떤 반가운 뉴스까지 있었고 그래서
일단 사실은
마에 트리플 크라운이 되느냐 안
되느냐 이게 이제 고민이었는데 코스피
8천 삼성전자 30만 원 하이닉스
200만 원이
>> 세 부분을 오늘 가볍게 셋다 장중에
갑뿐하게 뛰어넘으면서
>> 올라간다라고 마음 먹으면 거침없이
오를 수 있다. 우리는 뭐 튀어나갈
준비는 돼 있다. 우리 에너지가이
정축되 있다. 이런 모습을 좀
보여줬기 때문에 저는 뭐이 정도
에너지를 오늘 확인했기 때문에 앞으로
추가적인 악재가 뭐 어마어마한게
나오지 않는 한 어 탄력을 좀 받지
않을까 이런 생각을 하고 있습니다.
>> 아 이게 기대가 이게 기대할 수 없는
숫자예요. 어 그렇죠. 어 이게
상상할 수 있는 숫자가 아니거든요.
그럼에도 불구하고 우리는에
>> 더 위를 한번 바라보는 거죠.
>> 네.
>> 예. 근데 추가적으로 아까 권행커님
말씀처럼 이제 환율마저 조금 이제
잡혀진다라고 하면 뭐 더 고민할 거
없죠. 네. 조금 남아 있는게 이제
미국과 우리의 금리 이슈 정도가 남아
있는데
>> 어
>> 우리 쉬는 사이에 케빈 미국
연준의장이 정식으로 취임을 했어요.
근데 이제 트럼프 대통령이 또 덕단
비음으로 하면서 쟤는 내 말을
알아들을 거야라고 하면서 어 그분이
안 올릴 걸 뭐 이런 얘기를 은근히
했고
>> 시장의 분위기는 적어도 급격한 인상은
틀어막을 수 있지 않을까?
그렇다면 내린다라는 기대는 다소르지만
시장의 기대와 상관 저 상반되게
거칠게 올려붙이는 상황은 조금 핸들링
되지 않을까라고 해서 미국 금리 관련
조금 기대하는 상황이고
>> 우리도 이번 주에 이제 금통위가
있거든요. 근데 이제 우리 금리
관련해서는 이제 인상으로의 피벗 신호
정도는 나오지 않을까라고 예상하는데
>> 제가 볼 때는 나오거나 말거나
>> 연말까지 뭐 한두 차례 인상, 또
연말부터 내년까지 뭐 두 세 차례
인상 이런 다양한 시점을 끊는 거에
끊는 것에 따라서 다양한 전망치는
있는데 제가 볼 때는 우리 금리
인상은 우리 시장에는 크게 영향 주진
않을 것 같다라고 저는 개인적으로
전만합니다. 왜냐면 이미 어 시중
금리가 두 세 차례 인상분을 반영하고
있는 수준이기 때문에 사실은 따라
붙어 주는 것도 큰 충격이 없고 없고
증시에는 큰 충격이 없고 오히려
환율정이 조금 더 도움이 되지 않나
싶어서
>> 금리 관련한 이슈만 다소 미국과
우리가 조금만 이제 핸들링 된다면 뭐
이제 진짜 거칠 일이 별로 없지
않을까 이런 생각이 듭니다.
>> 네. 그래서 권정코님 아까도 이제
말씀하셨는데 외국인들이 시장에서 사고
있는 건 역시 반도체입니다. 가장
중요한 건 이익이 증가하고 있는데
그만큼 주가가 못 올라왔기 때문에
일종의 밸루에이션 그 평가 매력이
있는 거 같아요.
>> 네.
>> 이런 상황에서 내일 드디어 삼전과
닉스에
>> 두 배짜리 ETF가 나옵니다. 드디어
나오게 됩니다.
>> 아 이거 되게 공교롭지 않아요?
재밌지 않아요? 네.
>> 이게 되는 집안은 되는 거예요.
>> 보통 그렇잖아. 그죠? 이게 되는지
마약 막 트럼프가 난리치는데 이거
나와. 예.
>> 그럼 돼요, 안 돼요?
>> 아유, 관심도 없죠.
>> 그러니까 오히려 막 뭐 이건 막
망했다 뭐 이러 했는데 야 이게
대한민국 집안 잘 된다 이
>> 되는 집안이다.
>> 예. 이거 요거 설명해 주시죠.
>> 네. 단일 종목 레버리지인인 인버스
ETF가 내일부터 신규 상장이
됩니다. 쉽게 이야기해서 삼성전자랑
SK 하이닉스에 하루치 상승률
하락률을 곱하기 두 배로 추종한다라고
보시면 되고요. 이거 그냥 살 수는
없고요. 금융투자 협회 금융투자
교육원에 들어가서 홈페이지 들어가서
교육 과정 두 가지를 완료해야 어
지금 매수가 가능하다라는 말씀도 붙여
드립니다. 어 그래서 16개가
나오는데 지금 설정 금액이 좀
중요하다라는 이야기가 나오고 있어요.
왜 설정 금액이 중요하냐부터 설명을
드리면 투자자가 레버리지 ETF의
단기 매매를 선호하는만큼
매도 매수 호가의 충분한 형성을
중요하게 볼 가능성이 큰데 총 자산은
이런 호가 형성과 비례하는 관계이기
때문이다라는 이야기를 하고 있습니다.
그래서 지금 표로음 내일 상장되는
16개를 제가 정리를 좀 해
드렸고요. 함께 체크를 해 보시면
좋을 것 같습니다.
>> 그런데 보수가 좀 다르던데요. 네.
맞아요. 네.
>> 보수도 좀 많이 달랐으니까 어디라고
말씀을 드리겠?
>> 아니요. 왜 얘기해야지?
>> 얘기해도 돼요?
>> 아니 일단 보수가 높은 건 나쁜
거죠. 그렇죠.
>> 예. 아, 똑같은 상품 운영하는데 왜
수료 많이 받는
>> 거예요? 우리는 무조건 수수료 높은
거 배제합니다.
>> 어디예요? 제일 높은게 어디예요?
>> 삼성.
>> 삼성이야.
삼성 코덱스. 야, 죄송합니다. 야를
빼겠습니다.
>> 삼성 코덱스 보수가 제일 높아.
순수료가 왜 높은 거예요?
>> 보수표는 없나요? 저건 보수표
아닙니까?
>> 보수표를 제가 아, 그 보수표예요?
>> 아니, 이거는
>> 이거는 지금 예상 설정.
>> 아, 이거 농담 못 읽었구나. 네.
>> 진보 보수를 얘기.
>> 아. 아. 아. 아.
>> 자. 자, 여기 보수표는 없어요?
우리 마련
>> 우리 보수표가 제가 이전에 해 드려
가지고는 아마 체크가 안 돼 있는 거
같긴 한데 보습가 여러분들 그냥
검색만 해 보셔도 사실 기사에 많이
나와 있어요. 그냥 레버리지 뭐 뭐
수수료 보수 이렇게만 하시면 바로
나오니까 그거 상품별로 확인을 해
보시면 좋을 거 같고 제가 저 총
자산 규모를 말씀드린 이유는 진짜
이게 매수 매도 효과가 안 잡히면 살
수도 팔 수도 없게 되거든요. 똑같은
걸 다 같이 상장하니까. 음라고
이야기를 하고 있네. 근데 저제가
생각하기엔 유동성이 확보된 자산이기
때문에 그 걱정을 할 필요가 있나요?
>> 아니 이제 정확하게는이 정도 자산이
정도 ETF 가지고 뭐 유동성이
딸리고 그럴 상황은 아닌 걸로
보이는데 같은 값이면 그럼 지금
16종이 나와 있기 때문에
>> 그죠?
>> 네. 생각해 보시면 똑같이 삼성전자
내지는 하이닉스를 사는데 그리고
수익률도 어 삼성전자 하이닉스 원물
주가에 연동돼서 곱하기 2로 위로
붙든지 -2로
어 손실이 더 키우든지 둘 다
똑같습니다. 뭐든지. 그럼 뭐 해요?
집가운데 가면 되나? 뭐 이런게
아니고
어 그게 아니고 이제 굳이 이이
>> 회사마다의 장단점을 좀 편하게
설명드려 본다면
아 설정액이 큰 회사로 들어가면 이제
다양한 사람들이 호가를 많이
내잖아요. 난 지금 팔 거야. 난
올릴 거야. 뭐 이렇게 하면서 어
그렇기 때문에 호과 단위가 굉장히
촘촘하고
>> 또 많다. 그리고 설정이 크면
>> 회사가 사실은 그 LP 그래서 유동성
공급자기 때문에 효과를 내 줘요.
예.
또잠깐순간
좀 어려운 기원하고 ETF에 괴율도
생기거든요. 요거를 회사가 딱
막아주기에도 굉장히 편하거든요.
그러니까 투자하시는 분들 입장에서는
>> 내가 마에 드는 회사 이름 뭐
그것보다는 사람들이 많이 좋아하는
그래서 같은 값이면 설정이 큰게 조금
더 나중에 거래하기 좋다 이렇게
생각하시면 되고요. 또 하나는 원리가
똑같은데
>> 굳이 뭐 내가 보수 수수료 많이 주고
살 필요가 뭐가 있어? 같은 수익률을
받는데 거기서 아껴야지라고 하기
때문에 보수표를 쭉 비교해 보시고
제일 보수 적게 나가는 그래서
설정액이 크고 또 보수가 적은 이런
걸 정하시면 되지 않을까 싶습니다.
>> 그런 의미에서 삼성이 설정 금액이
제일 큽니다. 그래서
>> 그러면서 보수료가 거의 두 배 정도
안 되나? 하여튼 하여튼 제일 높은
거 같아요. 근데 중요한 건 일단
근본적인 질문을 좀 해보자는 거죠.
자,이 레버리지 ETF를 투자할 거냐
갈 거냐?
>> 자, 이거에 대해 답을 주셔야
됩니다.
>> 아, 레버리지 ETF 사실 저는
반도체 노출도가 높으신 분들이 정말
이건 근본적인 마론인데 현금이
있으실까라는 생각을
>> 좀 들어요.
>> 반도체를 지금 매수하셨던 분들을
분명히 우리가 소위 시장에서 말하는
추격 매수를 하셨을 가능성이 굉장히
높은데
>> 그럼 현금을 남겨 두셨을까? 살
여력이 되실까라는게 1번이고요.
그럼에도 불구하고 지금 나는 반도체에
대한 노출도가 너무 없어라고
>> 한다면 충분히 매력적이지 않나라는
생각을 합니다.
>> 네. 박수 대표님
>> 이게 제가 말씀드렸는데요. 이제
우리가 뭐 어 지금 보스표 나오를
또 우리 제작진이 또 잽진이
너무 흘렸네요.
>> 네. 저렇게 보시면 예를 들어서 뭐
>> 차이가 많아요. 예.
>> 그렇네. 네.
>> 저 삼성 코덱스 거의 두 배네.
그죠?
>> 근데 그 설정액도 보시면 두 세 배
이상일걸요.
>> 네.
>> 네. 설정액도 높긴 합니다.
>> 뭐야? 삼성편이야?
>> 아니게 아니라 장단이 그러니까 제발
>> 아 우리 보수만 봐.
>> 자.
>> 네.
>> 예.
>> 그래서 이제 저번에도 제가 한번
말씀드렸는데요. 예를 들어서
>> 네. 변동성이 큰 상황에서는 손실율이
커져요. 그러니까 예를 들어서
>> 100원에 출발했는데
>> 10%가 빠졌어. 그러면
10% 손실 나니까 이제
90원이잖아요. 그런데 이거는 곱하기
2로 맞으니까 80원의 손실이
나와요. 그러니까 삼성전자가 10%
빠지면 이건 -80에 걸리게
되거든요. 그래서 다시 삼성전자가
10% 올랐어. 그러면 80에서
10%가 올라가니까 20%가 올라가는
거예요.
>> 그러면 96이에요. 그죠?
이 안 됩니다. 이런 식으로 몇 번
왔다 갔다 왔다 갔다 하면 결국에는
같은 수익률 구간을 원로 그니까
삼성전자 원물 주식으로 왔다 갔다
하는 거에 비해서 어떻게 되더라도
무조건 손실이 커지게 되거든요.
그러니까 투자하시는 분들이 내가 아
삼성전자나 하이닉스가 요렇게 변동할
거 같아라고 생각하시는 분들은 안
하셔야 되고요. 어, 그래도
일방향으로 올라갈 거 같아라고
판단하시는 분들은
>> 수익을 두 배 이상 가져갈 수
있으니까 그런 판단을 하시는 분만
자신 있는 분만 하시면 좋고
>> 그럼에도 불구하고 중간에 잠깐 왔다
갔다 할 때 손실이 날 가능성이
있거든요.
>> 그래서 그거를 좀 견뎌낼 수 있는
정도의 여유 자금 계신 분들이 하셔야
되고 또 하나는
>> 그동안 삼성전자 하이니스 우리가 다
많이 갖고 있다고 생각하는데
>> 난 좀 놓쳤어. 어 그래서 지금이라도
따라붙어야 돼라고 생각하시는 분들
입장에서는 그 기간에 놓쳤던 수익률을
빨리 만해할 수 있는 예 그런 또
매력도 있으니까요. 이런 걸 좀
고려해 보신다면 적어도 초보은 아니고
>> 아니고 그전에 반도체 관련 비중이 좀
낮았다. 그죠?
>> 그리고 이익금이 좀 많아서 여유돈으로
할 수 있다. 이런 분들한테는 매력이
있을 수 있습니다. 네.
>> 네. 근본적으로 저희가 레버리지널
인버스 이렇게 좀 위험한 자산인
배제합니다. 그게 원칙이에요. 어
대신
>> 이런 상품에 대해서 저희가 어쨌든
시장에서 거래가 되고 이것도 엄연이
어떤 투자 상품의 일종이기
>> 때문에
>> 저는 관심은 가질 필요가 있다. 근데
무리하게 관심 갖지 말자. 네.
그래서 대표님 말씀처럼 여러분들이
이제 그동안 주식 투자를 해오셨는데
예를 들면 한 100만 원 정도
수익이났다 그러면 그냥 잠깐 제안해
드릴게요. 그중에서 10만 원 정도가
만약 있으시다면 그 정도를 하면서
출발을 좀 해 보시면 어떨까? 음,
>> 말씀드린 것처럼이 상품은 어,
변동성에 투자하는 거기 때문에 상당히
뭐랄까 위험한 투자 방법입니다.
그래서 어, 주식을 처음 하시고
그리고 좀 어, 자신이 없으시고 좀
더 경험이 필요하신 분들은
지양하셨으면 좋겠다는 말씀을 꼭
드립니다.
>> 그래서 금융위에서 지금 나온 뉴스 한
가지만 보여 드리면 아예 금융위에서
이렇게 얘기를 했어요. 삼성전자 SK
하이닉스 레버리지 나오면 변동성 있을
수 있다. 투자자 유의 사항이라고
아예 예 했고요. 그래서 단일
종목이기 때문에 리스크 있고 두 번째
지렛대 효과 있고 세 번째로는 말씀해
주신 음의 복리 효과 그리고 괴리율
함정요네 가지가 있을 수 있다라는
점을 금융위에서 미리 이야기했습니다.
>> 네. 그래서 처음에는 생각했던 거보다
이게 지금 히트가 많이 될 걸로 지금
보여져요. 네. 그래서 이제
어깨에서도 특히 이제 오랜만에 이제
자산운영 회사들은 신나 가지고 지금
현재 가입 이벤트 경품 막 이런 거
다양한 행사를 하려고 하는데 금융위가
하지 마 너무 히트될 거 같아 참어
이래 가지고 갑자기 행사가 취소가
됐어요 진짜.
>> 맞습니다. 그렇게 해야죠. 아니,
이건 물건을 파는게 아니에요. 투자를
하는 거고 그런 차원에서 물건을 파는
것처럼 뭐 백화점에서 세일할게 뭐
파세요 뭐 이런게 아니거든요.
>> 그래서 여러분들이 자기 책임화에
고민하시고 최대한 리스크가 없는
자금으로 어 그리고 소액으로 만약
관이 있으시다면 그렇게 하셨으면
좋겠다 말씀드.
>> 근데 이제 재밌는 거는 이광님이 우와
우리 되는가 봐. 코스피 되나 봐.
이런 말씀해 주시는게 뭐냐면 이게
새로운 다이나믹을 만들거든요. 원리
하나만 설명드리면
>> 야이 우리는 그래 뭐 곱하기 2를
준다는 걸 믿고 상품을 가입하는 건
좋은데 어떻게 곱하기 2가 나와 이게
이제 원리가 궁금하신 분들을 위해서
말씀드리면 여러분이 예를 들어서
>> 네
>> 1을 투자하시면 그 1에 해당하는
주식 그 삼성전자 주식을 한다
삽니다. 회사가 예 사요. 그리고
곱하기 2를 만들어 드려야 되기
때문에 나머지를 이제 파생으로 채우게
돼요. 파생 상품으로. 그렇기 때문에
무조건
>> 현물을 사요.
>> 네.
>> 그렇기 때문에 삼성이나 하이닉
입장에서는 어 내버려도 되는데 새로운
ETF가 히트가 되면 될수록 현물
주식을 사야 되는 예. 매수 주체가
또 나오는 거예요. 예. 그러니까
이제맞에
>> 기존에 있던 삼성 하이닉스 갖고 계신
분들은 엎친대 아니 엎친다도 거지.
저번에 뭐라 그랬죠? 우리가 사자성
헷갈렸더니 딱 댓글을
달아주셨더라고요. 금상
>> 첨화
>> 하나 더 있는데 예 금상
>> 첨화입니다. 또 다른 수급이
잡히면서이
설정행만큼 원 삼성이나 하이넥스
주식이 또 사야 되지니까 예
다이나믹을 강화시킵니다. 네. 근데
음. 물론 삼성전자 SK 하이닉스가
실적 전망이라든가 시장 환경 등이 좀
불안하거나 안 좋으면 우려가 크죠.
네.
>> 그런데 여러분 뭐 다 아시다시피 이제
전망이 굉장히 좋고 또 실적 증가도
전망이 되고 그리고 지금 주가
수준에서도 글로벌하게 어 그렇게
고평가 받는 상황은 아니기 때문에에
저희가 관심은 갖는 건 어 관심을
가질 필요는 있다라는 말씀을 한번
드려 봅니다. 네.
>> 네. 좋습니다. 그리고 어 세 번째
뉴스로가 볼까요? 어쨌든 오늘 어떤
분도 댓글 주셨는데 오늘 기판의
날이냐 이렇게 얘기합니다. 여러분
이거는 권다영 앵커가 지난주에 픽을
해 드렸잖아요. 저희가 다 이게
힌트를 드립니다.
>> 도목하라고 나머지 공부를 시켜 드렸지
않습니까? 저희가
>> 주말 동안 공부하셨을까 모르겠어요.
네. 어, 삼성전기가 현재 17%
넘게 오르면서 158만 원 지나가고
있고요. 삼성 전기만 가는 건
아닙니다. 어, 3화 콘텐서 상한가,
아모텍도 상한가, 지금 코칩, 대주
전자 재료 이런 종목들 상승세
이어지고 있고요. 반도체 기판
관련해서 LG 이노텍 21%
대급하면서 105만 원, 인텍
플럭스, 삼성전기, 코리아 서킷트,
이소페타시스까지도 모두 두 자릿수에
급등을 하고 있습니다. 어, 금요일
날 사실 말씀을 많이 드려서 기판이랑
MLCC가 비싸지고 있다. 쇼티지
그러니까 지금 부족 현상이 나타나고
있다. 근데 그게 초입이다라고 하면서
SK 증권에서 삼성전기 목표 주가
200만 원으로 올려줬고요. 오늘
LG노택은 제가 어디였는지 정확하게
기억은 안 나는데 NH였나요? 어,
목표 주가 70만 원 수준이었었는데
130만 원으로 올려줬습니다.
>> 음.
>> 그
>> 네. 그건 좀 늦었어요. 음.
>> 우리 지난번에 보여줬던 뭐였죠? 그
엔비디아가
>> 어 HBM을 새로 투자하면서 올라가는
금액 한번 볼 수 있을까요? 비님?
아
>> 뭐였죠? 블랙웰에서 루빈으로 갈 때
가격이 얼마나 저 한번 볼
MLCC가 어떤 거에 해당합니까?
>> 저기 밑에 있어요. 세 번째
>> 세 번째 줄 있죠?
>> 잘 보세요. 저희가 아주 흥미로운
지점이 있어요. 금액이 크지 않죠?
>> 음
>> 그죠? 전체에서 차지하는 비중이에요.
그래서 가격 형폭이 커질 수 있어요.
음.
>> 다시요.
>> 우리가 이거이 제품을 만드는데
>> 원가가 이만큼 들어가. 이거 가격
오르기 쉽습니까? 가격이 올라가면
사람들이 안 쓸걸요.
>> 그리고 너무 비싸다고 할걸요. 그런데
이거 만드는데 원가 요만큼 들어간
원가예요. 근데 이거 갑자기 가격 두
배 올리자요. 그러면 쓰는 사람
입장에서 아이 그래 해.
>> 아 그거 얼마 된다고.
>> 아 200원 주고 해. 바로 그
지점이에요. 그래서 지금 가격 상승을
얘기하는 거예요. 그렇게 되면 회사는
>> 다시 한번 회사가 쓰는 입장에서
부품이 얼마 안 돼요. 가격이. 근데
갑자기 두 배 올려 달래
>> 보니까 아이 그래 너네 알았다 해.
>> 이런 거죠. 지금이 상황에 있는 거
아닐까라고 보는 겁니다. 그렇게 되면
그 개별 만드는 회사 갑자기 가격이
두 세배 올라가니까 뭐 엄청난 속도
온 거죠.
그게 의미가 있는게 실제로 그
대장격인 삼성전기 같은 경우도 오늘
뭐 160만 원 선까지 뭐 가야 많이
하고 있는 상황인데요. 예.
>> 어 실제로 지금 현재 엄청난 호황인데
>> 음
>> 생산 케파는 현재 90에서 98%까지
다 쓰고 있다라는 거예요. 그러니까
더 돌려도
>> 네
>> 호항이어도 물건을 좀 더 만들어
내기는 어려운 상황이에요. 그럼
어떻게 주가가 계속 오르냐? 음
그 Q가 안 늘면 늘어야 되는데
한국말로 해주세요.
>> 네. 가격을 올려붙이면 돼요. 하나
팔던 거 두 개 팔고 세 개 팔아서
늘릴 수는 없으니까
>> 만 원에 팔던 거 야 이제 오늘부터
2만 원이다. 사람들이 이걸 사 줘야
되거든요. 근데 지금 그럴 수 있는
여력이 있다는 거잖아요. 예. 이건
대표님 말씀은.
글로벌하게
본에 있 대에 있고 이렇게 있국에 있
경쟁체제 있는 회사들이 다 가격
상승을 지금 하고 있는 중이에요.
그니까 여기까지도 할 수 있다라고
보면 뭐 지금보다 주가 상승을 위로
점치는 거는 근거가 있다. 다만 근데
이제 진짜로 오늘 160만 원
>> 터치를 했습니다. 때문에
>> 이게 200까지 갈 수 있을지 요건
이제 한번 좀 생각을 해보고
>> 예
>> 또 증설이 말씀을 해 주셨는데 증설이
뭐 이제 이제 시작하는 단계라서 한
>> 뭐 2년 3년 정도 이후에나 생산량이
늘 텐데 이게 만약에 삼성전기만
그러면 약간 문제가 있을 텐데 글로벌
업체 다 비슷한 증설 시기를 맞추고
있습니다.
>> 음. 알겠습니다. 마지막 뉴스로가
볼까요?
>> 네. 네. 마지막 뉴스로는 조선주 좀
보도록 하겠습니다. 조선주가 한
10시 뭐 요때부터 갑자기 오르기
시작하더라고요. 그래서 이유를
찾아봤더니 이재명 대통령의 발언
덕분이었습니다. 이재명 대통령이 오호
미래형 첨단 강군 전환 서둘러야
한다. 핵잠 도입에도 속도를 내자라고
이야기를 하게 되면서 한화 오션
10% 급등하고 있고요. HD
현대중공업 9% 한국 조선 해양 같은
종목들도 6% 이상의 상승을 보여주고
있습니다. 안 그래도 저희 엄경아
선생님 오셔서 이야기 했었잖아요.
>> 그렇죠. 조선희 후모께서 친히
납치셨죠.
>> 저희가 다 계획이 네. 좋습니다.
>> 그랬더니 어떤 분들이 그 마이크
타이슨이 한 말을 올려 올려 주시다고
>> 뭐라고 하셨어요? 계획이 있으면 뭐
하냐? 한대 맞고 정신 차린다.
>> 누구나 다 계획이 있다.
>> 누구나 다 계획이 있다. 막기 처막기
전까지 맞아요.
>> 여러분 그렇게 자꾸 그런 자세
좋습니다.
>> 저희가 잘못한 거 계속 지적해
>> 주십시오. 여튼 조선주가 최근에 좀
반도체 뭐 MLCC 기판 가는 동안
쉬었다가 오늘은 좀 상승이 나오면서
한 4월 정도의 가격대까지는 그래도
회복에 성공했습니다.
>> 네. 네. 감사합니다. 뉴스 정리해
보고요. 오늘 뭐 시장이 워낙 좋아서
저희가 뉴스를 좀 짧게 해
보겠습니다네.
>> 오늘 저희음 뉴스가 들어간 것 중에
뭐가 있었냐면음 뺐어요. 일부러
정영주 회장 이야기가 있었는데 왜
뺐냐?들을 가치가 없다. 그래서 그냥
빼버렸습니다. 예. 그래서 저희는
그냥 계속 저희가 하던 캠페인 계속
해 나간다.
>> 네.
>> 음. 그래서 12시에 만나서 하는
캠페인을 저희가 만들었습니다.
>> 어떤 캠페인이냐면 일단 두 가지예요.
첫 번째는 자, 박정 대표님
>> 스억 가지 말고 코스닥 사자 차라리
주식 사자예.
>> 그죠. 그죠. 띠를 만들었습니다.
네. 자,
>> 투쟁.
>> 세상에 제가 봤더니 정영주 회장한테
투쟁이 필요해. 예. 우리는 투쟁으로
갑니다. 이제 여러분 여러분 수벅하지
말고 우리 예. 주쟁입니다. 우리는
주식산
>> 글로점 한 번만 담아 주시면
우리 투쟁으로 합니다. 어울리나요?
>> 아니, 좀 해보셨잖아. 투쟁 투쟁
투쟁 전문이죠, 제가.
>> 예. 그리고 두 번째 캠페인은 뭐냐면
개인이 투자 없다. 우리는 국민
투자자라고 한다. 이거 우리
캠페인입니다.
>> 그리고 세 번째 캠페인이 있어요.
예. 권장콘님이 하는 것처럼 동만으로
간다. 가자.
>> 네. 이거 여러분 세 가지 저희가
계속 얘기드릴 겁니다. 끝까지.
끝까지.
>> 네. 네.
>> 음. 음. 지난주에 스억 말할 때
그러니까 어떤 분이 댓글 줘서 어
우리 딸이 스억에서 일하는데 어떻게
하면 좋으냐 고민을 많이 했는데 오늘
정영진 회장의 말을 듣고음
>> 다른 생각을 좀 하게 됐습니다.
뭐냐면 볼모를 잡고 있잖아요. 어 뭐
잘해 줘야 된다. 그건 뭐냐면 이러
사람들 또 얘기하잖아요. 그건 별개의
문제예요.
>> 그걸 회장이 나와서 얘기하는 거는
저희 고민을들은 거 같아요.
>> 음
>> 근데 저희 생각해 보겠습니다. 저는
만약 많은 사람들이 스타벅스에 가지
않으면 다른 곳에 가겠죠. 그러면
다른 곳에 고용도 증가하고 좋아질
거기 때문에 아 조금 시간을 갖고이
상황을 일단 타괴하고 투쟁해야 된다.
거기에 우리가 초점을 일단 맞춰
보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 네.
스타벅스에서 일하시는 분들 조금만음
참아 주시고 어 또 우리가 함께한다는
생각으로 어 너무 스트레스 많이 받지
마시고 그렇게 해 주셨으면 좋겠다는
말씀을 다시 한번 드립니다. 어 이런
차원에서 저희가 강연보 한번
드릴까요? 5월 30일하고 31일 날
일산 파조하고 위래 송파에서 여러분
뵙고 아 빨간때 한번 매고
>> 매고 출격하십니까?네
>> 여러분. 예, 깜짝 소식입니다. 아,
토요일 일요일 중에
>> 어느 한 군데 건다영 앵커 님이
출동하십니다.
>> 출동.
>> 여러분 드디어 권다영 실물 영접
가능합니다.
>> 그래서 여러분 주식 아가방 검색하시고
그리고 저희가 어,
주아가.co.kr로
오셔서 신청해 주시면 여러분 뵙고 또
이렇게 즐겁게 한국의 주익 시장
얘기하고 투자 방법 이야기하도록
하겠습니다. 예. 종원 뉴스 어
정리해 보고요. 2부로가 볼까요?
네. 김영 교수님 기다리고 계십니다.
เฮ
예, 여러분 2부 시작해 보도록
하겠습니다. 어, 우리 편이죠. 예.
아주대학교 김겔 교수님 오셨습니다.
>> 와,
예, 교수님 감사합니다. 저희 월간
김경이라 했는데 허락 없이 만들었는데
어떻습니까? 아, 사랑합니다. 아,
>> 아, 저번에 나와 주셔 가지고 반응이
너무 좋았어요. 최고.
>> 저
>> 스도 막 어마어마하게 날
>> 사실 제가 나온 걸 잘 안 보는데
어, 그 4월 27일 편이었거든요.
>> 어, 그다음에 이제 왜 우리 이제
5월 1일 날도 또 한번 일부 방송해
줘 그거를 하니까
>> 저랑 같이 한 28년째 살고 계신
여자분이 한 분 계시는데
>> 그만 보라고
>> 그런 걸 나르시시즌이라고 한다고.
>> 그래서 네.
어 근데 저도 굉장히 그 호흡이 잘
맞고 사실 또 가치관이 또 비슷해야
세계 세계관이 비슷해야 얘기를 나누기
편해지거든요. 그래서 저에게도 참
고맙고 의미 있는 자리였습니다. 네.
저희 조그만 바람이 있다면
김경은수님이 한 달마다 한 번씩
오셔서 여기서 힘을 받고 가셨으면
좋겠다. 이유는
>> 그래서 제가 계속 본 거예요.
>> 고맙습니다.네.
>> 근데 지난번 나오셔서 하신 말 중에
많은 분들이음 김경호수님이 말씀 너무
좋았다. 실제로 도움이 됐다.
>> 불을 타라.
이거 너무 좋았다. 그 말씀하시면서
많은 분들이 그 실제로 그렇게
하셨더라고요.
>> 네. 어, 뭐 저저는 또 그 말을 또
제가 드린 말씀을 열심히 실천하는
지난 달이었습니다. 네. 실천
잘하셨어요.
>> 어우. 네. 그리고 이제 어 제가
말씀드린 것도 실천했지만 어 우리
이광수 대표님 하지 말라고 하신 거
또 샀어요. 다른 주식을
>> 아 포트폴리오 계속
>> 당연간 기업을 보면
>> 어우 너무 사고 싶어요. 대표님도
똑바르고네
저기 계신 직원분들도 일 열심히
하셔서네
>> 그래서 20만 원어치씩 어네 번 아
다섯 번이구나 다섯 번 샀죠
>> 지금 김호수님 되게 심각한
상황입니다. 아, 김수님 오늘 저희가
드릴, 그러니까 같이 나눌 이야기가
굉장히 심각한 얘기예요. 그래서 이걸
해결해 주고 가셔야 돼요. 진짜
중요한 얘긴데.
>> 네. 네.
>> 자, 배가 아프다.
>> 어.
>> 아. 자,이 문제를 해결해 주셔야
돼요.
>> 배가 아프다. 자, 주가가 오가 8,
>> 8,이 막 가고 주가가 오르고 막
지금 MSC 주가 막 20% 30%
오르고 이런 이렇습니다. 배가
아프다. 이거 어떻게 해결해야
됩니까?
>> 그 배 아프다는 걸 우리가 이제
질투한다라고 얘기를 표현하죠.
심리학에서선 배 아프다 표현은
없으니까요.
>> 아, 그래?
>> 아, 이게 심리학 용어가 아니었어요.
>> 네. 아, 배픈 거는 아, 그
질병이죠.
그 내과나 이런 데로 가셔야 되고.
근데 이제 두 가지로 나눠요.
부러워한다와 질투한다.
>> 네네. 네.
>> 그런데 어, 저희는 보통 이렇게 많이
말씀드리죠. 불러. 근데 시체말로는
부어하면지는 거다라고 말씀을
드리잖아요. 근데 되게 재밌는 건 어
저희는 그렇게 표현 안 하고 불러하면
오히려이기는 거고 질투하면지는 거다.
네네.
>> 왜냐면 어 이제 옆집 농부가 소를
샀는데 그 소에 농사가 잘 돼요.
>> 그러면 부러워하면 나도 그런 소를
가져야지.
>> 예라고 생각하게 되는 거고
>> 그다음에 질투하면 옆집소가 죽어야지.
아라고 생각하는 건데
>> 와
>> 지금 배 아프다는 거는 전형적으로
질투고요.
>> 그러면 옆집소가 죽어야 되는데
투자하게 돼 있어요. 그건 투기
투자가 아니죠.
>> 와.
>> 네. 네. 네. 그러니까 지금 너무
정확한 말씀이신데 자 주가가 올라서
일단 그 뭐라 그럴까 배가 아픕니다.
근데 두 가지 부류로 나눠질 수
있겠죠. 하나는 부러움. 그러면 제가
열심히 좀 뭐 12시에 만나도 보고
공부도 좀 해서 투자를 시작하는
거죠. 이건 바로 부러움이고 질투하면
뭐냐면 인버스를 막 사는 거야.
>> 떨어져라, 떨어져라 망해라, 전쟁나라
이러는 거네요. 어 너무 이해가
되는데요. 그래서 저는 부럽다라고
얘기하라고 자꾸 얘기해요. 그냥
부러우면 인정하다. 그러니까 나도
가지고 싶다. 그런데 질투 나 안
부러워. 저거 별거 아니야. 그럼 흙
망할 거야. 그럼 망해야 되죠.
>> 네. 그러니까 부럽다라고 흔쾌히
얘기하는 스타일의 사람들은 어 결국은
같이 잘 아 그 배를 타고요.
>> 음
>> 그리고 얘기 안 하고 웃기고 있네.
이렇게 질투하는 사람들이 대부분
>> 어 기본적으로 망하거나 아니면
잘못되는데 조금 더 관심을 많이
가지죠. 아,관계도 마찬가지예요.
>> 그래서 제가 야, 그냥 부럽다라고
승쾌히 얘기하는 사람들이 되라고
얘기하고
>> 입국 다물고 아유 저 자식이 성공한게
별거 있겠어. 저거 운이 좋아서 저런
걸 거야. 질투하지 말라고
말씀드리죠. 네.
>> 너무 좋다. 부럽다고 말을 해라.
네.
>> 네.
>> 나 스스로 또 남에게 스스로 이제
인정하는 거죠. 인정부터 시작해야
되는구나. 그러니까 이제 어떤 나라든
나라의 동력이 있고 그 나라의
에너지가 있는데 좀 흔쾌하게
부럽다라고 이제 표현을 많이 하는
국가일수록
>> 그런 이런 주식 시장에서도 그렇고
다른 투자 시장에서도 그렇고 한쪽이
어느 어 일부의 사람들이 쭉서
올라가면 오 그래 우리도 할게라고
하는 쫓아가는 현향이 있죠. 아
>> 그런데 이제 질투가 많은 사회에는
조금 그런 동력이 떨어지는데 물론
질투는 강한 에너지이기 때문에 우리
드라마에서 모든 막장 드라마에서 뭐
엄청난 예예 뭐 신의 레벨에 해당하는
에피소드는 전부 다 질투의 화신들이
만들잖아요.
>> 그래서 강력한 에너지가 많은
나라일수록 질투가 많은 것도
사실이지요.
>> 그럼 교수님 부러워요. 아까 그 옆집
소가 들어와서 농사가 잘 된게
부러워까지는 좋은데
>> 부러워만 하는 사람도 있고
>> 이제 질투는 이제 나쁜 거니까 소
죽어라 이런 거고
>> 부러워 그래서 나도
>> 소를 사야지 여기까지 가는게 또 한
단계가 필요한가요 혹시
>> 그렇죠 아무래도 부럽다라고 얘기를
하거나 표현을 하면 아까 말씀하셨던
것처럼 그걸 공부하게 될 가능성이
많아져요. 네. 음. 그리고 그것에
대한기를 많이 하게 될 가능성이
높아지니까 아 굉장히 많은 경우에
우리가 살아가면서 어 알고 있는 많은
능력들이나 가지게 되는 그런 안목들이
교육받아도 되는게 아니라
>> 네.
>> 에케이션 교육이죠. 아니야. 그 러닝
학습되는 것들이에요.
>> 학습되는 것들. 그러니까
에듀케이션 교육은 커리큘럼이 있어요.
그런데 이제 전 국민 주식 관련된
투자 교육이 가능하겠죠. 네. 근데
그거는 무엇이 중요하고 어떤 것이
필요한지에 대해서 아주 필수적인 것들
로드맵이 있죠.
>> 근데 학습은 뭐냐면
>> 굉장히 많이 우리가 알고 있는 많은
것들이 학습이에요.이
>> 스튜디오에 앉아서 이걸 진행하시는
많은 것들도 교육받으시는게 아니라
학습되신 거잖아요. 그렇죠?
표은
사람도 좋은 사람이 되셔야 되는데
>> 그럼 그런 학습 능력이 좋은 사람들은
어떤 사람들이냐라고 봤더니
>> 아주 가까운 옆에 사람들의 말에 너무
좌우되는 것도 아니고 그리고 매우
매력적인 사람이거나 아니면 그럴듯한
사람에게 현혹되는 정도 적으며
>> 음
>> 약간 나와 크게 관련이 없는 느슨한
관계에 있는 사람들이 하는 말을
문득문득 그때마다 하나씩 쌓아가는
경향이 강해요.
>> 네네.
>> 음. 그렇구나. 이게 공부자라는
사람들의 특징이기도 합니다.
>> 오.
>> 왜 그 어 김익칸 교수님이라고
기록하게 대부이셨 예. 김미칸 교수님
말씀하시는게 이러죠.
>> 어이 근데 이게 투자와도 너무 잘
연결이 되는게 공부 못 하는 친구들이
이렇게 한대요.
>> 그대로 받아는데.
그래서 그 사람이 기하는 거 하나도
안 놓치고 그대로 따라가려고 한대요.
>> 그런데 공부 잘하는 친구들은 이런
데입니다.
>> 음.
오케이. 이렇게 했죠. 한 줄
적는데요.
>> 또 한 2분에서 뭐 3, 4분 정도
쭉 됐다. 음. 이것도 한 줄
적는데.
>> 그러니까 자기 생각이 있는
사람들이니까 이게 정리가 되겠죠.
음,
>> 그러니까 자기 생각이나 자기 주관이
어느 정도 있는 사람들이
>> 학습 능력이 좋으니까 부러워할 줄
알면서도 자기 주관, 자기 정의를
내리는 사람이 될 필요가 있어요.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 어 내가 무언가를 계속 뭐
하나도 안 틀리고 이렇게 받아
적으려고 하는 사람. 네.
>> 그렇다면 나는 아직 뭐 할 사람이
아니고요. 더 중요한 건 한 문장도
빠 빠지지 말고 잘 받아 적으세요
하는 쪽도 나쁜 사람들이에요.
>> 네. 그러니까 대부분 요런 거를 하는
사람들이 있어요. 네. 네. 네.
하나도 빠뜨리지 말고 다 지금
소화하셔야 된다.
>> 이거 그대로 하세요.
>> 네. 네. 네네. 그러니까 어 진짜
도움되는 사람들은 본질적으로 그러니까
중요한 건 이런 거예요.요 정도
얘기하는 사람들이 제일 괜찮은 느슨한
거리에 있는 사람들이죠.
>> 그런데 대부분 그런 사람들 말은 어
아주 지금 극단적으로 내가이 순간에
사 말아. 맞아요.
>> 요런 행동을 하는데 바로 도움이 안
되니까.
>> 그러니까 왜 맛있는 음식이 자극적이지
않는 것처럼 아, 그니까 영 몸에
좋은 음식이 자극적이지 않은 것처럼
자극적이지 않은 그런 말을 하기
때문에 잘 안 받아들이려고. 그러니까
>> 교수님 굉장히 중요한 말씀하셨는데 그
일종히 저희도 그런 뭐랄까 많은
분들한테 어 투자의 학습을 알려 주는
그런 일을 하고 있잖아요.
>> 그런데 두 종류로 구분을 해 볼게요.
그러니까 정확하게 알려주고 자극적으로
알려주는 부류가 있을 테고 좀
느슨하게 알려주고 원칙에 대해서
얘기하면
>> 후자 같은 경우에 사람들이 재미 없이
느껴져요.
>> 그죠?
>> 그래서 후자는 돈이 안 됩니다.
>> 그렇죠?
전자 정확하게 찍어 주고 지금 사
그리고 뭐 팔아 이게 좋아 뭐 두 배
갑니다. 이렇게 해야 이렇게 해야
그게 돈이 되거든요.
>> 그런데 그 전자로 하면 도움이 안
된다는 말씀을 하시는 거잖아요.
>> 그러니까 도움이 정말 되는 아
그렇죠. 전자는 정말 도움이 안
되죠.
>> 어 특히 왜 그러냐면 후자가 더욱더
제가 지난번에도 말씀드렸지만 잔소리
같거든요.
>> 아 그렇죠.
>> 잔소리. 저희들이 연구해보면 일과
투자의 가장 중요한 차이가 일은요.
>> 어, 안 해야 될 거를 좀 해도 해야
될 걸 안 하면 큰일 나는게
일이거든요. 그죠? 근데 투자는
대부분 아시겠지만
>> 해야 될 걸 하는 것보다 훨씬 더
중요한게 안 해야 될 걸 안 하는게
진짜 중요한 투자잖아요.
>> 그렇죠. 그런데 저희들이 보통 이런
얘기를 많이 합니다. 크게 사람을
설득하고 그다음에 한번 감화시키는 건
일할 때 되게 필요해요.
>> 음. 해야 될 하게 만들 때 필요한게
그 사람을 강하게 설하고 한번
감동감주는 거거든요. 그런데 안해야
될 걸 안 하게 만드는 거는 이런 큰
소리가 아니라 잔소리예요.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 투자에 대한 학습 능력을
높이는 가장 중요한
>> 사실은 기본적인 교육적 기본은 안
해야 될 것들을 잘 정리해 주는
잔소리꾼이 필요하다라고 늘 말씀을
드리죠. 제가 죄송합니다. 지난번에
출연했을 때 자 그 잔소리꾼 되시라고
말씀드렸는데 오늘도 또 세분을
잔소리꾼
>> 아 제가 교수님 그 말을
>> 엄청 그 각인하고 제가 그래서
화를내는 거예요.
>> 아 근데 말씀드리면서 전음
이제 아까 말씀하신 것처럼 부러움과
질투를 구별하면서 이건 구조의 문제도
좀 있겠다. 그럼요.
>> 예. 어떤 사회가
>> 그게 부러움의 대상이 되는 것들이 더
많은 사회가 있고
>> 그리고 질투가 많은 대상이 많은
사회가 있잖아요. 뭐 아주 극명하게
구별하면 이런 거죠. 같은 투자를
해서 돈을 벌었는데
>> 주식 투자에서 돈을 벌었습니다. 근데
이건 내가 할 수 있는 거잖아요.
>> 네. 네.
>> 내가 조금만 뭐 관심을 갖고 그리고
작은 금액을 할 수 있고 근데
누군가는 누구 어떤 분야 어떤 경우에
막 부동산으로서 돈을 벌었어요.
이거는 할 수 없는 거죠. 그래서
부동산으로 돈을 벌 때 질투가
커져요.
>> 주식보다 훨씬 더. 그래서 우리가
생산성 있는 부분이라는 얘기도 하고
그런 건데 갑자기 전 그 생각이
나더라고요. 그러니까 구조도 중요한
거 아닌가?
>> 그럼요. 그 구조를 우리가 어떤
눈으로 바라보느냐에 따라서 사람은
자기가 어 소위 말하는 다룰 수 있는
영역을 넘어가 버리면 이게 장엄하고
위대해 버리게 되거든요. 예. 그렇게
되면은 그 영역에 대해서 어 약간
환상이라든가 이제 판타지를 가지기
쉬워지죠. 그래서 저쪽은 뭔가
신화적인 것들이 존재할 거야. 음라면
그다음는 가지고 있는 이런 저희들이
라냐면 자기의 소박한 과학적 그
믿음이라고 표현해요.
>> 그니까 개인의 소박한 과학적 믿음이
들어가기가 제일 좋은 데가 바로
뭐냐면 내가 얼마든지 내 손으로 할
수 있는 것. 예. 흡연을 바라보는
관점. 뭐 예를 들어 주식을 바라보는
관점. 혹은 예를 들어서 자동차를
바라보는 관점. 이건 내가 손이 다
손을 닿으면 손을 내밀면 닿는
영역이거든요. 요때는 사람들의
검증되지 않는 과학적 신념이 엄청나게
많이 작용하죠. 아
>> 그까 자동차나 가전 제품 고장나면
어떻게 합니까? 한대 때려.
>> 아 일단 쳐 봐.
>> 네. 네. 네. 그래서 일단 쳐보죠.
그렇죠. 네. 네. 주식도 약간 그런
자기만의 과학 아닌이
과학이 아닌데 이거를 그래서
심리학자들이 영어로 예전에 나이브
사이로지스트 같은 사람이다. 그
소박한 심리학자나브
사이언티스트, 소박한 과학자
흉내를내는 사람들이다라고 얘기를
하거든요. 한국 사회에서 고마음을 잘
치고 들어가는게 이제 제가 보기엔
리딩방이라고 저는 생각이 돼요.
그쪽에서 굉장히 아주 나이브
사이언스, 나이브 사이콜로를 굉장히
잘 가장하고 푸하거든요.
>> 앞뒤 전제가 다 안 맞는데 앞뒤 말은
맞아 떨어지는 그래서 전혀
비과학적인데 논리적인
>> 음
>> 비과학적인데 논리적인 말들이 굉장히
난무하거든요.
>> 네. 근데 이제 저희 심리학자들이 앞
전제나 아니면 이런 말의 기반이
하나도 안 맞는데 앞뒤 말은 다
맞아떨어지는
>> 요런 어 요런 말들을 아 이게 참
>> 그 영어로 이제 볼
심리학자들 중에 그 이런 다양한
국가의 이상한 리딩 방을 어 볼짓
제너레이터 그러니까 불짓 생성기의
재료로서 연구하는 아,
>> 근데 그게 끊임없이 나온다는게 전
되게 흥미로워요.
>> 그게 된다는 거 자체가 저도 누가
봐도 너무 사기 같은 느낌이
들잖아요.
>> 가끔 병 그 형사분들이 경찰 쪽에서
저한테 물어보세요.
>> 누가 봐도 말이 안 되는 얘긴데
이거에 속아가 속아 나가는 사람들,
소가 드는 사람들이 어떤 사람들이냐
>> 그러면 제가 늘 말씀드리죠. 첫째
잠을 못 잔 사람.
>> 아,
>> 요새 잠을 못 자는 사람.
>> 둘째. 어, 그러면서도 무의미하게
바쁜 사람. 네.
>> 아,
>> 셋째, 그러면서 외로운 사람.
>> 어머. 음.
>> 그러면 우리 사회에 지금 여러 가지
자기의 여러 가지 주의 문제로 잠에
들지 못하고 그런 과정에서 무의미하게
허둥지등되면서 바쁘고
>> 그 과정에서 또 관계가 단절돼서
외로운 사람들 이런 분들 엄청
많잖아요. 네.
>> 놀라울 정도로 말이 안 되는 얘기도
믿습니다.
>> 음.
>> 네. 네. 그러니까 우리가 건강하고
그리고 우리의 컨디션을 잘 유지하는
것도 어 굉장히 무의해 보이고 어떻게
보면은 상관이 별로 없어 보이지만
사실은 이런 말도 안 되는
이야기로부터 우리를 지키는 가장
중요한 그 수단 중에 하나예요.
만약에 저보고 어떤 국가의 정책을
담당하고 있는 분이 질문을 만약에
하신다면 저는 이렇게 답변드릴
거예요. 이런 모든 사기성 정보로부터
국민을 지키려면 어떻게 해야 되느냐?
음.
>> 그러면 저는 어 한시간씩 늦게
등교시키고 한 시간씩 늦게
출근시키시면
>> 아 너무 좋다. 너무 좋다. 예.
예예예.
>> 사실 정말 많은 문제가 인간이 잠을
앉아서 일어나는 거거든요.
>> 네. 예.
>> 20세기에 인간이 만들어낸 인재.
그러니까 사람이 친 사고 막 거대한
대형 참사부터 말도 안 되는 폰지
사건 하기 사건까지 여기를 저희
심리학자들의 눈으로 연해 보면 거의
예외 없이 아니 하나도 예외 없이
들어가 있는게 수면 부족입니다.
>> 음.
>> 잠을 자지 못하는
>> 그러면서 무의미하게 바쁘고 외롭게
단절된 사람. 아
>> 우리가 그런 분들의 수가 점점
늘어나고 있다는 걸 부인할 수가
없잖아요.
>> 그렇죠.
가지고 있는 지키지
그런 이상한 기되는 분들의 숫자가
늘어나는 건 어찌 보면 당연한 얘기가
아닐까 싶습니다.
>> 저희가 좀 전에 그 내일 출시되는
곱하기 2짜리 상품을 얘기를 했어요.
그래서 이제 저희가 조금 주의하실
분들은
>> 이런 막 변동성이 크고 막 위아래로
곱하기 2씩 막 왔다 갔다 하면 사실
마음이 엄청 떨리실 분들이 많으실
거거든요. 그런 분들은 좀
조심하시라. 아가들은 그 변동성 못
얘기낸다. 중고수 이상만 하시라.
이런 얘기를 잠깐 했는데
>> 이렇게 좀 뭐랄까요? 왔다 갔다
변동성이 크고 손실폭 크고 이런
것들을 잘 내가 견디는 사람인가 그럼
못 견디는 사람인가 반문했을 때 나는
좀 대범하지. 담담하게 예언할 것
같아 하는 사람도 있고 막상 그렇다고
생각했는데 갔더니 아니야. 음.
>> 그걸 못 참고 막 어 불안해 가지고
손이 떨리고 이런 분들이 계시거든요.
그런 걸 좀 알 수 있을까요? 심리
>> 나의 성향.
>> 음.
>> 뭐 일단 뭐 제가 철저하게 그런 걸
못 견디는 사람.
>> 그러니까요. 예. 뭐 저는 그런
>> 어떤 사람은 그거 안 된다야.
노력으로 안 돼. 이런 거예. 이런
그래프를 보면 어 그냥 저는 그냥
바로 그냥 심장지라는 오는 거 같은
그런 사람이라서 제가 그렇게 얘기를
해요. 지금 또 수만
명의 접속하신 분들께 제가 얘기를
했잖아요. 그니까 얘기하시라고요.
음.
>> 나 소심하다고.
>> 아
>> 왜 대범한척하세요?
>> 아 교수님처럼 이렇게 인정. 네네.
저는 심강연할 때가
청중들의 집중을 어 나한테 끌어
저한테 끌어 모으기 위해서도 있지만
제가 강연을 잘하기 위해서 먼저
하는게 있습니다.
>> 음
>> 저 지금 무지 떨려요.
>> 그리고 저 의외로 잘 삐져요.
>> 되게 소심하거든요.
>> 근데이 얘기를 왜 하느냐? 음.
>> 제가 흔들리고 실수해도 그것 때문에
무너지지 않기 위해서 하는 거거든요.
>> 세상에 제일 어 그 어리석은 사람이
자기가 가진 그릇보다 큰 척하는
사람들이거든요.
그러니까 저는 제가 안 되는
사람이다. 힘든 사람이다. 어우구나
있잖아.
>> 어 지난주에 아주 그냥 두 번 천당
지옥 왔다 갔다 했어. 예. 뭐 이제
그리고 이제 3월 달에 제가 많이
했던 농담이 있죠. 강연 때. 어,
세상에 어, MBTI에 아이랑 이만
있는게 아니라 있다.
>> 예. 그 티가 트럼프다.
>> 이러면서. 그러니까 제가 이분 때문에
못 살겠다는 얘기.
>> 그러면 내가 흔들린다는 거 싸겠다.
>> 그니까 제가 흔들린다는 걸 인정하면
그다음에 저희가 이런 얘기를 합니다.
그러면이 두 번째 말을 안 할 수
있어서 그게 그게 배우게 만든다.
>> 네.
>> 음. 음.
>> 흔들리는 걸 안 흔들리는 것처럼 계속
굴잖아요.
>> 그러면 자기가 예상하지 못한 결과가
나왔을 때 꼭이 말을 한다는 거예요.
저희들이 연구해 보면 내가 그럴 줄
알았어.
>> 음.
>> 근데 내 그럴 줄 알았어라고 하면
>> 절대로 못 배운다는 겁니다.
>> 왜냐면 알고 있었다고 생각하니까
>> 그 일 몰랐잖아요.
>> 그래서 내가 흔들려. 나 되게
그릇아. 나 소심해라고 사실은 감당할
수 있을 정도로 이렇게 흔쾌히 인정을
하시면 그다음에 내가 전혀 납득하지
못한 결과나 예상하지 못했던 결과가
나왔어요. 그럼 그때 뭐라고 얘기할
수 있냐면 내가 이렇 꿈에도
몰랐잖아.
>> 그러면 꿈에도 몰랐다라고 했을 때
그다음부터 뇌가 배우기 시작합니다.
>> 네네.
>> 그러니까 왜 모르면 모른다고 얘기하고
예상하지 못했으면 예상하지 못했다라고
얘기한다는게 그래서 중요한 거죠.
음. 그니까 저희가 주식투할 심리
얘기 가끔할 때 꼭 들어가는 것 중에
하나가 여러 책에서도 나오지만
겸손하라 이런 얘기 나오는데 결국
같은 말씀이시네요. 그래서
>> 인지적 겸손의 끝판항입니다.
>> 예. 음너 스스로 변성어나 이런
것들을 스스로 인정하는 거기서부터
출발 뭐가 돼야 되네요.
>> 근데 교수님 저희가 어제음
한 분을는데 그분은 미국의 빅테크에서
큰 회사에서 리크루트 채용을 하신
>> 분이었어요. 네. 근데 이런
말씀하시더라고요. 채용할 때 한국
사람과 외국 사람의 가장 다른 점이
있다. 한국사 그니까 한국 사람은
자기가 이만큼 가지면 조금
얘기한대요.
>> 근데 외국 사람들은 요만큼 가졌는데
예를 들어서 엔지니어들을 막
공학자들을 채용하는데
>> 저 뭐 잘 가는 거 우주선
만들었어요. 이래서 일종에 영어로
하면 블러핑 크게 한데요. 자 요런
어떤 그 국가의 차이 뭐 민족의 차이
이런 것들도 있겠죠. 정말 많이 좋.
>> 그런데 되게 재밌는 건
>> 그렇게 인터뷰 장면에서 확실히 한국
사람들은 자기가 100을 가지고
있으면 30이나 40 정도만 가지고
있는 것처럼 얘기를 하는 경향이 많이
관찰됐어요. 최근에 젊은
세대분들한테는 좀 덜 덜 나타나기는
하지만. 근데 그럼에도 불구하고 한국
사람들은 자기가 거기에 채용이 딱
되잖아요.
>> 그렇 이후에 내가 할 수 있는 일들은
훨씬 더 크게.
>> 예. 그다음에 굉장히 세게 오히려
평가하고 돌변하는 경향도 강한
>> 채용이 확정이 된 순간부터
>> 그죠. 그래서 우리나라의 모든
직장인들은 나 없으면 회사가 망한다고
생각을 하
>> 아주 그냥 뭐
>> 아 갑자기 안성이
>> 저 회사 때려치면서 회사 망할 줄
알았어요.
>> 그러니까
>> 근데 주가가 막 다섯 배 올라
>> 분명히 문화적 차이가 상당히 촘촘하게
존재해요.
>> 그러니까 좀 더 정리라고 자세히
들여다볼 필요가 있죠. 그래서 그
지점에서 전는 그냥 이렇게 그 얘기를
딱 듣는 수가 그러면 그 겸손과
연결돼서 아 한국 사람들이이
겸손하니까 투자를 더 잘할 수
있겠네라는 생각이 확든 거예요.
그럼요. 그래서 한국에 있는 많은
분들께
>> 하기 전엔 담대해져야 되지만 일어난
결과에 진짜 겸호해져야 된다라는
얘기를 드리죠. 어, 멋있는 말.
그니까 하기 전에 담대하고 그다음에
겸손하고 이거 계속 제가 하던
얘기거든요. 투자할 때 투자를 시작할
때 용기를 갖고
>> 그다음에 뭐냐면
>> 어, 대응한다.
>> 네.
>> 요지죠. 그렇죠. 반대로 가는게
뭐냐면 하기 전에 소심했는데 누군가의
말에 또 끌려서 가고 난 다음에
결과는 마치 알고 있었던 것처럼
이렇게 굴면 아무것도 교훈도 없고
나아지는게 없는 그런 일들이 계속
벌어지겠죠. 그럼 교 또 하나 질문해
볼게요. 예를 들면 오늘도 지금
코스피가 8,100이고 삼성전자
30만 원이고 하이닉스 지금 200만
원 넘었거든요.
>> 자, 이러면 이러면 누가 또 질문을
해요. 그래도 지금 사요. 예를
그렇지 해요. 그럼 제가 뭐하는 줄
알아요? 사요. 이렇게 그냥 딱 찍어
줘도 오늘부터 더 갈 거니까 사라
그러겠지라고 하면서 그래 이렇게 하는
분이 계시고 아니야. 내가 사면 꼭
빠져. 어. 이렇게 얘기해서 오히려
어떤 똑같은 상황이 생겨도 지금
오르고 있으니까 더 갈 거라는
긍정적인 뷰를 보고 거기에 배팅하는
사람도 있고 아니야 올랐지만 나부터
꺾일 거야라고 이렇게 부정적인 생각을
먼저 하는이 심리적인 차이
>> 그게 사실은 그 사람의
뭐 아들러 같은 심리학자들을 얘기를
해 보면 책이고
킹
>> 자연스럽게 또 아
>> 이게 가장 최근에 나온 책인데
>> 자연스럽게 들어갑니다. 사실이
아들러가 제가 너무 좋아하는
철학자인데 또 김경교수님이 최근에 또
책을 번역을 해주셔서
>> 번역까지요.
>> 예. 너무 you speak
engish
>> 대단하십
>> 미국에서 하기를 맞으셨어요?
그러니까이 바쁘신 나와중에 또 코리안
씨를 제가 또
>> 아 근데 예 아들러 예
>> 어 이제 아들러와 같은 많은 그
심리학자들이
그 사람이 보이는 그 모습이 상당
부분 그 사람이 아주 고유한
컴플렉스에 관련이 돼 있거든요.
그러니까 내가 지금 가지고 있는 약한
모습 있잖아요. 약한 모습이 어 내가
가지고 있는 꽤 오랫동안 만성적인
어떤 문제가 해결되지 않고 있다라고
생각을 한번 해 봐야 될 필요가
있어요.
>> 근데 이걸 너무 이제 심리적인 문제로
가서 막 뭐 정신 질환이나 병리적인
측면으로 갈 필요까진 없지만 한
번쯤은 우리가 어른이 돼 가면서 해야
되는 중요한 생각 중에 하나가 내가
왜 자꾸이 말을 반복하고 있지?
>> 어.
>> 아. 이걸 한번 체크를 해 봐야
됩니다.
>> 음. 심지어는 그 결과가 좋다고
하더라도 그리고 그 말이 긍정적인
언어라 하더라도 그리고 심지어
타인들이 타인들이 나의 말에 찬사를
보내더라도
>> 네
>> 내가 왜 자꾸이 말을 다른 말보다
많이 반복하고 있지라고 하는 걸 한번
점검해 볼 필요가 있다는 거죠.
>> 음.
>> 어 예를 들자면 저는이 말을 참 많이
반복해요.
>> 그렇구나.음이 음이 말을 참
반복해요. 근데이 말을 반복하는
이유는 아마도
>> 모든 사람과 잘 지내려고 하는 약간
어 현실적으로 불가능한 그런게 좀
있지 않을까라는 생각을 한번 해 보는
거
>> 그러면서 자기 자신을 한번 체크해
보고 체크해 보고 체크해 보는 거죠.
>> 맞아. 전 가장 많이 하는 단어가
있어요. 뭐냐면 쉽게 이야기하면.
>> 어 생각한테 항상 쉽게 얘기하면이
말씀 많이 하시고 또 이해하셨어요?이
얘기 많이
>> 그러니까 저는 거기에 약간 강박이
있는 거 같아요. 많은 분들이 쉽게
알았으면 좋겠는데.
>> 아, 내 말이 어려울까 봐.
>> 어, 사실은 선의고 좋은 결과를
만들어내는 말이죠.
>> 하지만 거기에도 나만 가지고 있는
다른 사람들과는 차별화될 수 있는
어, 다른 매우 나만의 오랫동안 밑에
있는 컴플렉스. 이게 컴플렉스라는게
꼭 자격 지심이만 컴플렉스가
아닙니다. 내가 평생에 걸쳐서 해결해
나가야 할 나만의 문제라고 보시면
제일 좋을 것 같아요.
>> 그러니까 그게 나의 능력이자 곧 나의
약점이 될 수도 있거든요. 그러니까
진짜 그 얘기 많이 하시죠. 쉽게
얘기하자면 그렇죠. 음. 그러니까
이해시켜야 된다고 하는게 정말 순고한
나의 임무를 나에게 조준 소명을
수행하고 계시지만 동시에 이게 나의
저 깊은 시면에 있는 해결되지 않은
무언가의 가능성이 크죠.
>> 다시 투자로 돌아오면 심리학자들이
이런 얘기 많이 합니다. 나의 투자
엔태를 보면 그래서 나의 시면을 볼
수 있는 너무나도 깊은 예. 그런 그
출발점이 되는게 네. 그러니까 저는
>> 어 소위 말해서 불타기를 너무 잘해서
되게 뛰어난 것 같지만
>> 이렇게 손절 못하는
>> 그러니까 분명히 저는 떠나보내지
못하는 무언가
>> 사실 그런게 있는 거죠.
>> 네.
>> 네. 한 가지만 더 그럼 얘기 좀
여쭤보면
>> 내가 오늘 사자 이렇게 딱 결정을
했어요.
>> 네. 딱 창을 열었는데 맞나 안 맞나
요걸 다섯 시간 보고 있다. 팔자
그랬는데 아유 요거 아유 팔아야 되나
봐 시간 보고 나는 많아요.
핵심은 마지막 순간에 결정을 못
하는이 결정장에 호소하시는 분들
많거든요. 이성적으로 다 하기로 마음
먹어 놓고
>> 음
>> 그런 분들에게 결정을 좀 과감하게 할
수 있는 아니면 당신의 문제는 뭐다
이렇게 얘기할 만한게 있을까요? 아,
이거는 돈 내고 들어야 될 거
같은데.
>> 맞아요. 제가 지난주에 LG 전자
추가 매수 때 하루 종일 공연하다
그니까 구경 시간 하다 끝내 못
사시는 분 많거든요.
>> 저는 뭐 장 열릴 때부터 네. 네.
장 끝날 때까지 네. 그래 가지고
이제 아, 이걸 어떡하나라고 생각을
했었는데
>> 어, 뭐 심리학자들이 이런 얘기 많이
합니다. 자기 원칙 세 개를 정해라.
이렇게 이렇게 세 번 다른 각도로
생각했는데 같은 결론이면 그렇게
한다. 자기 약속을 지킨다. 인간은
그냥 요렇게 앉아서 생각하면 그냥 한
종류의 생각을 하는 것처럼
>> 어 점심 먹고 난 다음에도 물 마시고
난 다음에도 예를 들어서 뭐 하고 난
다음에도 뭐뭐 하고 난 다음에도이
각기 다른 세 번에 뭐뭐 하고 난
다음에도 같은 결론이면 그걸 해라라고
하면 좀 실천을 잘합니다.
>> 나의 결정을 돕는 몇 가지 원칙을 딱
만들어 놓고 들어맞으면 한다.
그런데 또 하나 단어서는 내가 지쳐
있으면 어떤 경 종류에 결정도 못
한다.
>> 자고 일어나서.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 그래서 저는 주식 투자에 주식뿐만
아니라 모든 투자를 잘할 수 있는
방법 중에 하나가 뭔가요라고 하면
저는 건강을 잘 유지하시고
>> 팔기차게 살아가시라. 그래서이 책
제목이 트래킹이에요. 전이 제
>> 그래서 뭐냐면 트래킹이라는 건 결국
운동 얘기하는 거잖아요. 꾸준하게
운동하는게 대명사인데 또
트래킹인데마트
>> 그걸 또 사용하신 거예요. 그래서
네. 그래서 어떤 사람이 지혜로운가
이런 표현을 저희는 안 쓰고요.
>> 나는 요때 지혜로 지혜로
지혜롭습니다. 어떤 사람이 더
창조적이고 혁신적인가요? 그게 아니라
나를 창조적으로 혁신적으로 만드는
상황과 시점을 잘 알고 있는
사람이라는 표현을 저희가 쓴 거든요.
>> 그니까 투자도
>> 내가 좋은 투자를 할 수 있는 상태를
알고 있는 것도 되게 중요합니다.
>> 그래서 그런 거 있잖아요. 나는 언제
매수하면 성공하는데 몇 시에 매수하면
꼭 실패하더라 하는 분들이 계세요.
>> 그런 분들도 상당한 저희도 일집장에서
보면 고수예요.
그거는 절대 어 소박하고 그다음에없는
근거없는 과학이 아니라 자기 직관의
작동 방식을 잘 이해하는 아주 굉장히
경험 많은 분들이라고 저희들은 보죠.
>> 아 오늘도 너무 좋네요. 저희가 월간
김경희를 이제 매월 할 건데요.
>> 네.
>> 그냥 제 제가 그냥 이거는 허락이
없었어요. 아 저는 그냥 SNS
올리려고요. 네. 오늘부터 월간
>> 아 근데 목표를 해야겠다. 뭐냐면
저희가 이게 쌓이면 책을 그렇겠네요.
책을 하시죠. 주식과 심리를 얻어서
그래서 투자와 심리와 해서 저희가
같이 책을 만들고
>> 12시에 만나요. 이제 공적으로
가시면
>> 아 좋습니다. 아 너무 좋은데요.
이렇게 계획을 또 세워보고 어
교수님하고 같이 끝까지가 보도록
하겠습니다.
>> 절대 안 놔 드려.
>> 예. 저희 한번 물면 안 넘니다.
저기 그 내기에서
승부 난 다음날 불러 주세요. 같이
좀 얻어 먹게.
>> 아, 좋다.
>> 저희 지금 내기 제가 하나 낼게
있거든요.
>> 그 내기 하는 날 아직 집행일이
정해졌어요. 오세요, 교수님.
>> 저대하겠습니다. 네.
>> 네. 교수님 저희 많은 국민
투자자분들에게 마지막으로 한 말씀
부탁드립니다.
>> 저는이 얘기를 언젠간 한번 드리고
싶었는데
>> 어 투자로 성공하신 분들은 잘
관찰하시고 아직 그렇지 못하거나 어
많이 실패하신 분들을 잘 이해하셔야
된다. 양쪽 다 봐야 되거든요. 네.
어 그래서 어 인간이 왜 위만 봐도
끝이 없고 밑에만 봐도 끝이
없거든요. 근데 항상 보면 어느 한
쪽만 열심히 보면서
>> 어 그렇게 가는게 있거든요.
>> 그래서 오늘 하루도 투자에서 성공하신
분들 이야기도 잘 들으시고 그다음에
투자해서 실패하신 분들의 그 쓴
조언도 잘 하시면서 이렇게 균형잡힌
삶을 정말 그 한번 생각을 유지해
보시면 어떨까 싶습니다.
>> 아유 감사합니다.
왜 뉴스 공장에 책 들고 가면 이제
총수님이 그런 얘기 하죠. 책을
읽으려고 사냐? 그런
>> 아니 저희는 12시에 만나면 읽으려고
삽니다.이이 두 책은 읽을 만한
가치가 있어요. 여러분 김경훈
교수님이 최근 낸 어떻게 이렇게 또
금방이 차이도 안 나요. 몇 개월
차이가 안 나요. 그런데 이렇게
빠르게 다하셔서 여러분들이 관심을
많이 가주셨으면 좋겠고요. 그러셔야
제 나옵니다.
>> 아니 이렇게 했는데 하나도 안 팔리면
아이 뭐야 12만 뭐야 나 안
나갈래?이 이 이렇게 하실 거잖아요.
그래도 생색은 저희가 보여 드려야지.
크게 감사드립니다.
예. 저희 항상 함께 해 주셔서
고맙다는 말씀 다시 한번 드리고요.
어, 또 6월에 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
>> 네.
>> 여러분, 저희가 1시가 좀
넘었는데요. 그래도 계속 해
봤습니다. 김경 교수님하고 아주
유쾌하고 도움이 되는 말씀을
들었고요.
>> 방송은 시간이 좀 지났지만 그래도
사연을 좀 읽어 드리고 싶은게
있어요. 음.
네. 어, 제가 좀 읽어
드리겠습니다.
광수샘이 주식으로 번 돈으로 짜장면
사 먹지 말라고 하셔서 투자를 시작한
이래로 한 번도 매도하지 않았습니다.
초등학생 딸이 마트에서 간식을 사
달라고 해도 흔들리지 않았던 제가
어제 12시에 만나요를 보고 생각이
많아졌습니다. 어제 저희가 어떤
방송을 했냐면요. 기부에 관련된
방송을 했거든요. 그 방송을 보시고
이런 생각이 드셨대요. 내가 투자를
하는 이유가 무엇일까? 주식을 하나도
모르던 내가 누구 덕분에 이렇게 큰
수익을 올릴 수 있었을까? 부모님도
이렇게 큰 돈을 주신 적이 없는데
그래서 오늘 큰 결심을 하고 삼성전자
내주를 팔아 아름다운 재단과
홍길동원에게 100만 원을
기부했습니다.
공장장님도 시동샘도 투자를 오래하려면
나 자신에게도 가끔 선물을 주라고
하셨는데 최소형 PD처럼 실천하기가
쉽지 않네요. 나머지 20만 원은
저를 위해 써 보겠습니다.
아 12시 만너요를 응원드리고 그리고
어제 방송에서 말씀하신 기부 이야기에
모든 분들이 관심을 가졌으면 좋겠다는
말씀을 드립니다. 12시 만노에서
항상 응원드리고 그 선한 영향
나누겠습니다.
12시에 만나가 꿈꾸는음
선순환입니다. 아 저희가 어제
아름다운 재단과 그리고 홍길동은 어
안진호소장이 모셔서 기부 방송을
했는데요. 오늘 아침까지 아름다운
재단에 집게된 기부 금액이 무려
5,100만 원이라고 합니다.
>> 와.
>> 아, 여러분들 너무 감사드린다는
말씀을 드리고 음. 어, 세상을 바꿀
수 있는 힘이 사실 이런 데서 오지
않을까라는 말씀을 드립니다. 아, 한
가지 공지 사항은 여러분들이 저희가
그렇게 기부하셨을 때 아름다운 재단에
알려 주셔야 본인을 확인하고 그리고
영수중이 발급된다고 해요. 그래서
여러분들이 많이 참여하시고 기부금
영수중도 아름다운 재단을 통해서
발급받으시기 바랍니다.
여러분 너무 함께 해주셔서 감사하고
이렇게 같이 선수를 만들어 주셔서
감사합니다. 어이 눈물이 많이 나는
이유는 뭐예요?
다음 아이템.
>> 어, 원래 눈물이 많으셨어요.
>> 아,
>> 예. 그런데 그 눈물을 막아내고
있었던 2, 30년이 있지 않았을까
싶은 네. 저는 뭐 워낙 자주 울기
때문에. 네. 네. 여러분들이 이런음
댓글을 보고 그리고 소식을 드리면
감동입니다. 뭐 슬퍼서 그런 건
아니고요. 감동이 물듯이 넘쳐납니다.
여러분 너무 감사드리고요. 저희가 또
내일이 마음으로 찾아뵙도록
하겠습니다. 12시에 만나요. 함께
해주셔서 감사합니다. 고맙습니다.
감사합니다.
เฮ